JONATHAN MARCHAND
- Je ne me suis jamais senti
aussi bien.
- Après avoir passé près d'une
décennie en CHSLD en raison de
sa dystrophie musculaire,
Jonathan Marchand, 45 s,s,
savoure enfin une première année
en appartement.
- Maintenant, j'ai de
la spontanéité dans ma vie.
C'est moi qui su a au contrôle
de mon existence. Donc, je peux
décider quand est-ce que
je me lève, à quelle heure
je me couche, quand est-ce que
je mange.
- En quelques mois,
il est parvenu à se trouver
un emploi, à s'acheter une
voiture et à redevenir
financièrement indépendant.
Et le chèque emploi-service,
une allocation du gouvernement
provincial, lui a permis
d'embaucher des assistants de
vipopour lui fournir de l'aide à
domicile.
Mais son combat n'est pas fini.
Selon lui, ça prend une aide
plus ogarnisée pour que d'autres
puissent suivre son parcours.
- L'aide au recrutement de
personnel, par exemple,
comment gérer des employés, les
lois sur les normes du travail.
- À la veille des élections
provinciales, il souhaite voir
un changement de vision à
Québec. L'an dernier,
le gouvernement Legault avait
promis un projet pilote pour
facilir r les démarches,
avant de faire marche arrière.
- Il faut créer un programme au
niveau provincial.
- Parce que ça demeure
extrêmenent difficile de sortir
d'un CHSLD comme il l'a fait.
Surtout que les procédures
varient selon les régions.
Daniel Pilote, 60 ans, réside
dans un CHSLD en Montérégie.
Après un an de démarches,
il n'y a encore aucun plan
d'action pour le sortir de
son centre d'hébergment.
DANIEL PILOTE
- Ça peut être très, très
compliqué la communication
dans un centre intégré.
J'ai un peu peur pour ça,
que ça traîne trop en longueur
et puis que ce soit mal
organisé.
- À quelques jours du
dédéclenchement de la campagne
électorale, les partis se sont
tous engagés à mieux soutenir
les personnes handicapées.
En attendant, Jonathan Marchand
poursuit son combat, et profite
de son autonomie retrouvée.
- J'ai maintenant un futur et
des projets plein la tête.
Ici Flavie Sauvageau,
Radio-Canada, Québec.